le jeudi c'est pour qui s'écoule à elle
est là bas pour quitter la ma chérie
bien sûr si vous allez bien battre eh
bien franchement je suis tellement
heureux de vous voir
moi aussi oublié mille feux les goûts
c'est vrai mais combien coûte la vie
cela combien de kara elle est magnifique
on ne garde pas une marque merci pour
les offrir j'espère qu'on se rencontre
aura un jour un hymne celle là je te
griffoul ma chérie alors commencer
j'aimerais revenir sur une séquence dire
hier soir chez moi mon pauvre chéri vous
avez bien du courage
oui hier l'un vos chroniqueurs c'est un
petit peu trop lâché et ça en plein
direct résultats des contraires
décontraction général fous rires pour
tout le monde et même une petite enquête
parallèle qui a duré très longtemps
alors ça sous les yeux de michel drucker
alors donc hier c'est vrai que hier on a
cru qu'avec quelqu'un qui avait pété oui
on n'a toujours pas su qui avait pété on
aura l'enquêté alors c'est en plusieurs
fois en une seule fois ce en une seule
fois ben alors je vous le dis c'est
parti d'un bruit assez bizarre j'espère
c'est suspecte est parti de là nom de la
non de la casta diva ver là vous n'êtes
pas complètement à voile à l'arche
exemple au delà de tout soupçon dit ou
qui on saura dans un instant qui est la
personne qui a provoqué ce fou rire qui
est la personne qui a honteusement pt
[Rires]
40e cement pt au foot et cette personne
est honteuse quoi qu'il arrive
quoiqu'elle ait fait devant michel
drucker une légende la personne s'est
honteusement lâché avec elle mangeait
des flageolets ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'était de ce côté yade et
bernard montiel qui a déjà pété en toute
impunité jamais si on va dire ça mais
péter de ma vie à benjamin castaldi
qu'on ne présente plus dans le milieu du
calibre de béni oui oui voilà ai-je
envie et j'en ai envie mais pour moi les
drucker et michel dronier moi le
coupable est parmi vous 3 et imagine
cédric et michel drucker et si c'est
michel drucker ne peuvent plus
[Applaudissements]
dont on connaît cette année
vous saurez tout dans un abus on vous
montre tout ce qui se passe dans
l'émission et hier je vous le dis si
vous nous rejoignez il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes sur twitter qu'ils
ont peur qu'ils se disent qui a pété
qu'il ya aussi la télé sur une émission
en direct sur une émission de grande
écoute
mon fils m'a appelé pendant la pub je ne
vous le cache pas une aube a dit papa
j'ai peur qui a pété hier émissions se
dérouler normalement
paranormal quand tout à coup est un
bruit étrange bizarre étrange suspect un
bruit celle où a retenti dans ce
périmètre de sécurité
alors bien entendu j'ai été interpellé
par ce bruit il ya mille questions qui
me sont passées par la tête
quelqu'un at il pété
quelqu'un at il fait croire qu'il avait
pété pour me déboussolés quelqu'un a
essayé de faire croire qu'une tierce
personne avait pété pour déboussoler
cette tierce personne se passe-t-il
quels sont les enjeux de ce pays
la réponse je suis pas en mesure de vous
la donner actuellement je vais la
découvrir comme tout
[Musique]
avec vous pour qui
oui j'ai besoin de vous
j'ai besoin de vous j'aime bien le
savoir les dessous de ce fait nous avons
toutes les images terribles jeu on a
toutes analysées et je peux vous donner
un petit indice commune c'est celui qui
dit que ça pue qui a fêté généralement
est exactement je rappelle le vieil
adage
je rappelle en mai sur un an je vous
rappelle le veinage qui a mis à mal bien
bien bien des coupables
premier chanteur premier pétard on va
regarder des images invisible
âmes sensibles s'abstenir et surtout
quand on ne fait pas ça chez vous ça a
été réalisée par des professionnels et
elle est terrorisée la pluie on est allé
le chercher une robe elle voulait pas
sourire est passé dans les mains rien
elle avait 16 ans j'ai donné ma voix et
l'odeur bizarre on va voir le award du
moment embarrassant justement
richard
[Rires]
[Musique]
avoir informé mon tir du lièvre à
meschers
jetant lancement des trois centres
dentaires
les tarbais fit un stop stop ou qui sait
la première partie la wii c'est la seule
partie pourquoi parce que la triste
réalité s'il sait qu'on vous a menti et
on sait remo qui avait raison jamais eu
de paix c'est à dire mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé alors bravo c'est quelqu'un
dans le public a simplement tous ces
morts et ces petits bruits a fait grand
bruit effectivement tout va bien on y
croit pas fait de bruit siouplait elle
était de terroriser la pluie on essaie
de chercher une robe voulait pas sourire
elle est passée dans les mains rien elle
avait 16 ans
thierry siquet cas tous comme ça
j'arrivais à savoir combien alors on va
au bénéfice du doute mais feront leur
quête la poursuite genou et dont la
chose ma chérie bien sûr j'aimerais
c'est louis la petite nouvelle
ah oui par tiffany vide en scrutant les
images j'ai pu un petit peu apprendre à
vous connaître et je sais que vous
cherchez l'amour
ah oui si si si vous avez me fait un
petit portrait robot très précise de
votre mii idéal j'ai donc essayé de
trouver chaussure à votre pied autour de
la table et je peux vous dire que j'ai
bien galéré un mais vous regardez quand
même alors que vaut le coup ça
[Musique]
surtout pas de muscles
mais qui fait tout le temps car j'ai
déjà fait à manger
amusant voilà
[Applaudissements]
la sauver
comme ce soir
[Applaudissements]
attendez qu'elle a dit à la fois les
mecs musclés avec j'étais mort ah oui et
pas musclé 45 50 ans tu pas musclé mois
maintenant
michael alors les mecs et prothèses
c'est pas du muscle merci non mais pas
musclé sympa drôle
bon vivant oui j'aurais dû rajouter pas
marié quatre fois
[Applaudissements]
voilà on va vous avez votre réponse est
oui mais en même temps je n'attendais
pas grand chose
il a l'air un peu déboussolé histoire du
jeu n'est pas le style suis pas ni
peut-être alors pas du tout à nantes
pascal et sylvie n'a écouté va écouter
ça fait quatre ans qu'aucune me faisait
beau temps mais je dis qu'elles sont
belles mais al manar mais n'est-ce pas
dit qu'il ait des débats belge dit c'est
pas mon genre ouais ben ouais alors mais
moi je vous dire vous allez vois tu
cette forte que vous allez dire non je
sais je n'oublie votre femme
la vérité votre femme regarde pas est ce
que tu peux nier votre jambon bas non
pas du tout allez on va leur poser
mais n'allez pas me regarde pas c'est
votre fils ou pas ah non plus ça va
mieux le coup
[Rires]
c'est votre style
oui j'allais trop jeu mais ça pourrait
oui barrette salmi tout va bien venir
que kanye elle te dis ouais non pas
s'asseoir ensemble tu dis non non non je
dis non parce qu'elle est trop jeune je
vous dis non
métailié et là il est trop vieille trop
jeune ça aussi donc personne et votre
cilicie naba la lazio samedi tu veux je
te dise bon ben on est venu me taux
allaient alors d'autres rapts et oui
mesdames sandra nos noms et tarot l'idée
turbide à la plus chère est ce que
caroline ithurbide et votre style craint
lui ce nom
est ce que c'est beau oui mais
heureusement ce clip oui alors oui c'est
ça ben oui je vais mieux rires oui oui
oui oui mais si vous n'étiez pas avec
votre femme avec des si on mettrait
paris en bouteille mais bientôt être le
cas si vous n'étiez pas mes goûts et
femmes on est dans la fiction un
caroline ithurbide n'est plus avec son
mec aussi est ce que votre vue but est
de me ruiner ma vie mais je connais très
bien aurore elle sait très bien que
c'est de la fiction c'est mon ami je
veux dire votre femme je la vois
peut-être certainement beaucoup plus ou
moins
on s'il vous plaît accord elle installe
10e alors qu'est la question s'il vous
plaît vous la connaissez très méric oui
oui pourquoi pas voilà là bas tu sais
quoi
jaune alors tu pourras venir dormir à la
maison si luce tenais à vous remercier
du fond du coeur
pourquoi parce que vous m'avez venger de
toute cette méchanceté que delormeau a
dit sur moi non si bien sûr et je peux
vous dire que c'était une punition
commercy méritait vraiment merci
ciliberti chéri on a les mêmes bien sûr
qu'on analyse bien chez moi je les
envoie j'espère que l'époux qui
montreront ce qui va ne s'est passé
pendant ces jeux fait quoi tu ne peux
plus m'asseoir mauvaise image
enfin mathieu je suis debout qui
évidemment que les images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brasse pour matthieu lamoure à ça et
qu'on s'entend très bien battus et
montceau bah ça se voit ok oui vous avez
d'autres choses bien sûr cette semaine
cyril pour mon plus grand bonheur je
vous ai trouvé encore plus agité que
d'habitude et ça m'a fait tellement qui
fait que du coup j'ai fait une petite
compil encore cette chouette j'étais
calme paisible
allez on se régale la baguette
[Musique]
m
entrée libre
merci super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui a fait ça dans ta vie tu as ta place
qu'elle évite qu'elle est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma plus belle histoire d'amour
[Musique]
il est très sympathique
dwayne johnson et kevin hart au style
très sympa il m'a dit à moi de tout bête
mais naïve jeune et curieuse méthode ça
va ça passe tu as ta bouche chérie ça
passe ça va ça va pas conclure on a
d'autres choses moi chérie l'asie
meilleur civile
vous aviez dit que vous allez dire
aujourd'hui qui pourrait vous remplacer
ah oui c'est vrai alors c'est vrai que
moi tu donnes moi m'avait posé une
question hier il m'avait dit si vous
vous absentez trois mois qui vous
choisissez pour vous remplacer à la tête
de tpm paix j'en avais gardé encore
quatre en lice jean michel valery
benjamin et mathieu et je vais en
enlever 1 ce soir
voilà mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
non mais regardez les images
ah oui merde de l'équipe mancelle
sans langue de bois pour l'instant seul
choix entre quatre de leurs mots
castaldi jean michel maire valérie
benaïm oui c'est tout assez bons a à
l'époque et la part du couple
et maintenant maintenant on va voir qui
est une petite embrouille qui s'est pas
fait pas du tout bien sûr que si j'ai
les images où son nom
[Musique]
sur l'axé pour
bonjour les gars c'est l'interview
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas sur moi
[Musique]
dans les mois par son surpoids que c'est
quoi avant sa bonne chance pour
l'apprendre m'aviez sous les 50
[Applaudissements]
c'est mathieu battu pas l'aider sur 650
pages vous dit comme il est c'est
monsieur loyer j'enlève battue est vrai
je relève mathieu de l'important match
est très bon ouais bah oui je sais ça
tienne cette agression là c'est une
question d'éthique
voilà donc matthieu delormeau voilà elle
était où l'éthique pendant que magnéto
non l'été a vu pour corrompu font un
corrompu bon bout je comprends pas trop
vite et de façon je vous dire tu me
verras la vérité beinheim à la jazz
échos datés et mon idée elles étaient
précises depuis le début celui pour moi
qu'ai je à qui je donnerai ma place
pendant trois mois moi j'ai envie
brûlures c'est vrai c'est jean-michel
non
je regarde toi dont michel à ce que jean
michel c'est celui qui avec moi depuis
le début
ouais mine de rien c'est le plus ancien
c'est mon ami benjamin aussi bien sûr de
rien mais c'est plus anciens c'est
l'ancienneté c'est jean michel qui me
remplacera si un jour je vois la
première est pour moi savons pas si
c'est bien français des sous-titrés
[Rires]
allez on passe au de ringard de l'équipe
j'ai nommé fade et jaume i abbas et
saint paul alors tout ce qui est sorti
après 1980 eh ben ils connaissent pas
alors forcément quand la jeune chanteuse
eva coup il est invité sur le plateau
ouais ça donne ça allait on regarde
c'est une star en puissance va vous êtes
une queen de la chanson est votre
dernier single s'appelle rodéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les malades peuvent accueillir ici je
vous lis c'est un énorme carton canicule
ou confirme c'est un énorme carton et
les deux vieux schnock à côté de moi je
les balances et il se rappelait pas des
légendes vous êtes vraiment à l'ouest
vous a vraiment des vieux chênes à la
cour il semble en fait ils sont fans des
laissez passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs mais il va quid hadji donné
c'est vrai aujourd'hui six à huit plus
grosses tâches vous promets je
connaissais pas voilées partout par des
toits vas-y doit minute sortie de deux
de nos cinquante mille single c'est
important avait ou non mais tu la
connais ces packs windows sur nietzsche
vous connaissez gens me le grinch de
gris gris
voilà c'est ça eh bien vous savez lui le
bonhomme et great ouvert qui passe son
temps à râler
eh bien figurez vous que si on
repeignait je me bats ce serait pareil
ils arrêtent pas de râler regardez je
suis pas mal
on passe tout de suite à la vérité si je
mens buzz
[Applaudissements]
un escroc mythomane quelle est la
question comment vous sommes trop loin
ça va trop loin tu écris le petit
bonhomme en mousse en pensant à fabien
lecoeuvre non syrie en temps ça tâtonne
[Applaudissements]
j'en vois pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ameddah il a changé
j'aime bien la justice weepu qui
regardant les images suis tombé sur une
conversation comme on dirait irréel
contournant fêtait sa part de la
poitrine de kelly pour arriver jusqu'à
la sexualité de mamie zaza non ci est
tous en moins d'une minute chrono
franchement je n'ai pas vu venir et aux
faux ben alors les regarder comptez pas
voilà les stands étaient jugés par une
fille
[Musique]
qui les guide mes pas beaucoup de leur
moelle une fin mais un gros bravo
poursuivre sa très fort oui au prix
alors ça bien vous êtes décidément un
homme plein de surprises
fabien lecoeuvre car on joue avec ce
livre est bien là au fur et vous êtes
aussi pas qu'un petit puits de science
non bien sûr que non vous êtes aussi
influenceurs beauté bah oui mais c'est
le garder les heat wave et post
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'évoque étages et ramener des
sels de la mer morte
une fois par semaine avant oui
le simple manque affectif les le succès
les ports et pratique
c'est un gel d'aloe vera à l'autre
la coiffure des massages avec silver
exercice
non mais
passer les nerfs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
youtube c'est exceptionnel ça c'est
mélissa székely d'enlever d'enlever
cétacés ses antiennes vrai talent c'est
la toile passe contre aux états unis les
enlève en pic du lait de chèvre parce
que les chèvres mange la langue
ah oui mange donc on chante on en fait
pas donné une chaîne aurait directement
si l'on déduit la fête sur le dis parce
que on peut permettre de les taire sur
les partis donc on met on met du lait de
chèvre et sa part merci m grâce à vous
gens me la minute haute vous souvenez la
minute de plus et bien maintenant c'est
devenu la minute craddock mais la minute
raj de jambi et je vous laisse découvrir
pourquoi salle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est pas toi même
je dois vous le dire vous êtes
dégueulasse le personal je précise
c'était avant que j'ai mon oignons sinon
ça peut être sympa c'est bien c'est le
public qui applaudit doucement est
mitigé mathieu n'est pas là ce soir
encore non malheureusement il était là
quand même trois fois cette semaine il
sera là trois fois la semaine prochaine
on savait quatre fois je crois ce projet
moi je le connais un altruiste comme il
est il doit sûrement être en train
d'aider son prochain avec ses précieux
conseils
ah oui ces décès touchent autant et
dévouement pour les autres c'est
possible peux aller me tue le coach
c'est parti
[Musique]
qui croit beaucoup touché officiel du
numéro deux jours d'un droit ok je crois
pas non plus y prétendre
son émission bravo aux parigots super
jamais bac d'accord
[Musique]
c'est là c'est le
je te dire touche à ton cul tu auras des
verrues plus du jeu la soupe à l'aja ça
voudrait coaching personnel avec vous il
a encore l'espoir
il n'a pas compris que cet essai mort
yahya yahya parité est quand même peu de
réaction quand il veut toucher les
fesses et amicale
alors si vous n'avez plus d'amis
aujourd'hui posée bouley valérie je me
pose une question depuis quelques jours
en fait vous êtes à côté de gens me et
il lui arrive souvent de dessiner sur
ses fiches
alors moi j'aimerais savoir ce qu'il a
dessiné ce jour là pour vous réagissiez
comme ça on regarde vallery puis vous
les faites une petite poubelle juste
après pâques huawei merci
[Musique]
lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais quelle au fort
allez valérie pour les téléspectateurs
vous devez passe à table qu'est-ce
qu'elle a dessinée bas comme d'habitude
des appareils génitaux fondé ensemble et
tout ça à d'accord et dévoila vous avez
papa dans maman voilà d'accord très bien
on comprend merci alors d'autre choix
pour qui les dernières images crois oui
les oui c'est vrai a pris la saison
avance et j'ai un truc à vous montrer où
il ya d'autres cas montré exceptionnel
même moi j'ai de la peau qui a su faire
c'est cool ça me fait plaisir à l'opus
avance et plus j'aime beaucoup et eric
naulleau
la grèce est un véritable sniper qui
n'hésite pas à tacler tous ses petits
camarades sans aucune pitié et moi que
je prends mon pied comme dirait janvier
vous regarde
oui les grands moulins vous en demandez
pose à poil bien sûr vous êtes pourquoi
c'est quoi la marque qui demande de
poser à poil mythos
oui
jusqu'au bout j'ai suivi aveuglément
jennifer mais je préfère me trottait
jennifer qu'avoir raison avec la date
avec delambre moi je m'engage en
politique ça a été un petit parti
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]